[موسيقى]
ونحييكم من جديد في اول تعليق له على ما
وصفه بمحاوله اغتيال بحقه عقب استهداف سور
مطار سليماني الدولي باقليم كردستان
العراق بطائره مسيره تركيه قبل ايام دانا
قائد قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه مظلوم عبدي
هذا الهجوم رغم عدم اشارته الى وجوده في
مطار السليمانيه لحظه استهدافه واتهم
المسؤول الكردي في بيان اتهم الرئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان بالمسؤوليه عن
الحادث مضيفا ان رئيس التركي يحاول عبر
الهجوم كسب الانتخابات وخلق حاله من
الفوضى بين القوه الكردستانيه في اقليم
كردستان العراق المجاور بينما دانت قصد
ورئاسه العراقيه وحزب الاتحاد الوطني
استهدف مطار سليمانيه الذي اغلقت تركيا
مجالها الجوي امام رحلاته منذ الثالث من
ابريل الجاري حتى الثالث من يوليو المقبل
بيان المسؤول الكردي ياتي في وقت نفت فيه
القيادات العامه لقوات قاسات التعرض
قائدها لمحاوله كما نفت وجوده في مدينه
السليمانيه وطلبت رئاسه اقليم كردستان
السلطات الامنيه باجراء تحقيقات في الحادث
كما دعت الاطراف المعنيه الى ضبط النفس
والتعامل مع الحادثه وتداعياتها بطريقه
سليمه تجدر الاشاره مشاهدينا الى ان
استهداف مطار سليمانيه زاد من حده
الخلافات بين الحزبين الرئيسيين في اقليم
كردستان اي الاتحاد الوطني والديمقراطي
الكردستاني
نناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفنا من اربيل
الدكتور سربس نبي استاذ الفلسفه السياسيه
في جامعه كوريا اهلا بك ومن اسطنبول طه
داووجلو الكاتب والمحلل السياسي اهلا بكم
ضيوفي الكرام اسمحوا لي ان ابدا من
اسطنبول معك سيد اوغلو بتصريح قائد قوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه مظلوم عبدي الذي اتهم
فيه مباشره تركيا باستهداف صور مطر
السليمانيه وبالتالي فهم البعض باستهدافه
هو لخلط الاوراق لفائده الانتخابات
التركيه القادمه ما رايك في هكذا تصريحات
تحياتي لك في البدايه استاذه كريم ولساده
المشاهدين يعني من دون شك يعني هذه
العمليه والتوجه التركي في العراق هو ليس
جديدا وتعلمين ايضا ان المستهدف في هذه
العمليه هو مظلوم عبدي وهو الرجل المطلوب
لدى السلطات التركيه ولكن هنا هذه المره
الاستهداف هو في مطار السليمانيه مطار
مدني تعلمين تركيا تقريبا منذ عام 2021
ولا حتى هذه اللحظه هناك توغلات وعمليات
تشنها لملاحقه عناصر الحزب العمال
الكردستاني عود لسؤالك وخفض المتعلق هل هو
لامور انتخابيه على اتصور اعتقد هي ممكن
ان نقراها من زاويتين يعني الزاويه الاولى
وخاصه تحدثنا عن ان هذه الهجوم حتى لحتى
هذه اللحظه سلطات التركيه تنفي بانها هي
وراء هذه العمليه ولكن من ناحيه افتراضيه
نتحدث بان كانت هي رساله تحذيريه لقصد
خاصه ان المعلومات تحدثت بان هناك مسؤولين
امريكيين موجودون موجودين في الطائره في
هذا المطار وايضا يعني اذا انقر قامت بهذا
العمليه وتم اغتيال مثلا مظلوم عبد التصور
اعتقد سوف تكون كارثه بالنسبه للحزب
الحاكم هنا الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
خاصه في الانتخابات التي لم يتبقى الان
اقل من خمسه اسابيع يعني وهي سوف تكون
مغامره هناك من يرى بنى هي ورقه يكسب بها
رئيس القادم ولكن نتحدث عن ان هذا لن
يجازف تعتقد بان الحزب الحاكم في داخل
التركي لن يجازف بهكذا عمليه لانها قد
تخربط الاوراق ولكن في الاتجاه العكسي ما
رايك في هذا الكلام استاذ نبي
مساء الخير اهلا بك
لا على العكس من ذلك
لا انفي وانا ذكرت في اكثر من مكان البعد
الدعائي من وراء لان الرئيس التركي يحتاج
في ظل ازمات المتفاقمه والمشكلات التي
يواجهها الان داخل التركي الى غنيمه وعاده
غوغاء القوميين من جمهور الحزب العداله
والتنميه والرئيس التركي والحركه القوميه
عاده يحتاجون الى غنيمه من طراز
مظلوم عبده للتضحيه به التقديمه كقربان
لانتصارات على الساحه السوريه سيما ان
سياساته
في سوريا والعراق باتت عقابه قوسين او
ادنى من الفشل النهائي لكن ماذا لو فكرنا
خارج الصخب الاعلامي
والسيناريوهات المرسومه النمطيه التي باتت
سائده الان هل تركيا هي المستفيده الوحيده
ونتساءل هل تركيا هي المستفيده الوحيده من
وان كانت هي الرئيسيه والفاعله
المتحده ايضا بحسب معلومات خاصه بان
بنيتها في استهداف مظلوم عبدي في مطار
سليمانيه وهذا كان دافع الشخصي والرئيس
للرئيس التركي الا ان الولايات المتحده
حذرت تركيا من شان مثل هذه العمليه ان
تدفع
ان تقوض الكثير او تضر العلاقات الثنائيه
بين البلدين لا سيما وان هناك ضباط ضباط
امريكان مع مظلوم كانوا مع مظلوم عابدين
في الموكب نفسي وكانوا قادمين من الاجتماع
نفسه هذه مساله اولى اذا ما هي الدول
الشريكه والتي لها مصلحه في تحقيق ذلك على
الساحه السوريه تحديدا ليس هناك الان سوى
قوى وحيده منظمه في مواجهه تحقيق
السيناريو المصالحه بين النظامين التركي
والسوري
وايران شريكه ايضا استخباراتيا وقدمت
معلومات وهذه لاول مره اصرح بهذا الكلام
هنا من هذا المنبر وايضا روسيا
وتركيا جميع هذه الاطراف شريكه في محاوله
استهداف مطار سليمانيه لازاحه هذه العقبه
في تحقيق لان هناك عقبه اساسيه في التفاهم
بين والمصالحه بين ولكن نبي صحيح اسمحي لي
فقط اسمحي لي فقط
العقبه الوحيده هي قصد او تركيا تشترط على
نظام السوري
الانسحابها من شمال السوري تماما ومن
مساله ادلب هو ان يقدم النظام على التخلص
من قوات قصد في شمال شرق سوريا هذا هو
التفسير المنطقي الرئيس لا اعلم اذا كان
مظلوم عبدي على درايه بها ام لا ولكن هذا
ما يمكن استنتاجه استنادا الى بعض
المعلومات الدقيقه هناك اكثر من دوله
واكثر من طرف سياسي اشتركوا في محاوله
اغتيال او في سعي الى اغتيال او القصف في
مدينه سليمانيه هذا من جانب اللي بغرض
التمهيد للمصالحه النهائيه
ولكن صحيح نعم نعم دكتور نبيل وضحت هذه
الفكره اعطني على المقاطعه خلينا فقط نسمع
امر واحد المعذره هناك طرف عربي ايضا
متورط هناك طرف عربي متورط في العمليه هذا
الطرف سنرفع عنه حين نتاكد لان هذا الطرف
الان يمهد لعوده النظام الى جامعه الدول
العربيه بقوه حضرتك تقول بانه يجب علينا
ان نفكر خارج الصندوق ونطرح فرضيه انه ليس
هناك طرف واحد وذكرت ايران ذكرت روسيا
ذكرت امريكا ذكرت الاطراف الغير راغبين في
عوده العلاقات السوريه التركيه
المتدهوره اصلا سيقول لك بعضهم دكتور نبيل
بانه هذه الع المتوتره ليست بحاجه الى
اطراف اخرى لكي يوتروها الجانب السوري هو
من جهته عطل مسار هذا التقارب لانه وضع
شروط والجنب التركي لم يرى بد في تحقيق
هذه الشروط ولكن خليني اسال الاستاذ اوغلو
فيما يخص هذا السيناريو الذي قد يقول عنه
البعض ولكن تعلم حضرتك بانه في الفتره
الاخيره ليس هناك شيء مستبعد
سيد اوغلو ما رايك ثم يطرحه ضيفي من
سيناريو قادر على ان يكون ربما مطروح
يعني انا اتفق مع ضيفك بعض النقاط وخاصه
يعني هو ربط الموضوع بالتطبيع ما بين
انقره ودمشق نعم لاحظنا خلال الساعات
الاخيره الماضيه بان هناك تم تاجيل
الاجتماع الرباعي التركي الروسي الايراني
السوري الذي كان
مرتقى يعقد غدا الى المقبلون بسبب بان
هناك مشكله الانسحاب التركي من الاراضي
السوريه مشكله قصد هذه نقطه وهناك عقبه
العقبه الاساسيه يعني كما يقولون هي ايران
التي عطلت هذا الاجتماع ويعتقد ان النظام
هو الذي يضغط خاصه ان التي تقوم بهذه
العمليه بشكل كامل كبير وهذا الاجتماعات
اقصد هي روسيا ولكن اعود الى مطار
السليمانيه وهذا الاستهداف ايضا هذه
العمليه هي عمليه امنيه استخباراتيه
بالدرجه الاولى من دون شك يعني هذا
العمليه لن تحدث من دون ان تتصل معلومات
استخباراتيه الى السلطات التركيه هناك
يعني الجيش التركي وخاصه خلال الفتره
الاخيره يعني اتحدث عن عام او اكثر من
الان كل العمليات كانت هي تستهدف في
الشمال العراق وخاصه بالقرب من جبل قنديل
لاستهداف القياديا في عناصر حزب العمال
الكردستاني هذه المره وهذا المطار هناك
ايضا كما تعلمين هناك خلاف كردي كردي ما
بين الحزبين يعني الكرديين وايضا هناك يجب
ان لا ننسى كما ان اضيف على ما تفضل عليه
الضيف من العراق وخاصه هناك علاقه قويه ان
كانت امنيه اتحدث ما بين انقره واربيل
ولكن هناك سؤال اخر يطرح سيدتي وهو
المتعلق بالعلاقه التركيه العراقيه يعني
قبل اسبوع من الان كان هناك زياره للسيد
السوداني الى انقره وتابعت الزياره وخاصه
انها هي تحدثت بشكل كبير عن موضوع المياه
وكان موضوع الامني كان بعيد جدا حسب ما
تبعتنا للحدث هنا في تركيا
ولكن ممكن ان نتحدث عن فرضيه اخرى وهي
الفرديه ان يكون هناك اختراق امني بمعنى
الحكومه المركزيه العراقيه التي اليوم هي
انتقدت وطالبت يعني هناك الاعتذار من
الجانب التركي هناك بعض المعلومات وصلت
حصلت عليها سلطات فئه تركيه كيف يتم
الاغلاق المجال الجوي قبل يومين واعلن
المسؤول في الخارجيه التركيه تانجو بالجيش
بان هناك ارجع الاسباب
هو الموضوع المتابعه ولكن انتهى تماما
توقيت هذه الحلقه عبراني على المقاطعه
الدكتور سربست نبي استاذ الفلسفه السياسيه
في جامعه كويا ومن اسطنبول تعاوده الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي شكرا لكم السلام عليكم
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات